[Música]
ah
i
equinococosis
quiste hidatídico
estilo cocos y quística
así le dicen los científicos los
profesionales en las universidades en
los centros de investigación
en el campo
en las escuelas en nuestras casas en
vuestras casas hablamos de enfermedad de
las manos sucias de la enfermedad del
perro
del quiste
de la vejiga de agua o simplemente de
hidatidosis
esta enfermedad está extendida en todo
el mundo especialmente donde hay ovejas
y hay cabras
153 países al menos la tienen
no importa en qué país estemos no
importa qué idioma hablemos no importa
quién es el que habla hablamos siempre
de hidatidosis
una enfermedad crónica silenciosa
postergada olvidada
una enfermedad
que decimos que es parasitaria porque la
produce un gusanito muy chiquitito que
está en el intestino del perro decimos
que es una zoonosis porque afecta a los
animales y a nosotros a ustedes es una
enfermedad grave
porque no se enferman afectan nuestros
pulmones nuestro hígado
es una enfermedad costosa porque curar a
cada chico con hidatidosis nos sale muy
caro
también porque afecta a nuestros
animales y estos producen menos lana
menos carne menos leche
la organización mundial de la salud
aquella que rige la salud en el mundo
dicen que hoy en este momento habría un
millón de afectados en todo el mundo
en la argentina hoy se van a enfermar
cuatro chicos
y en nuestra provincia de chubut se
enferma uno por semana
no tiene el campo en la meseta de la
patagonia argentina
hace muchos años
en el campo ovejas y perros
gracias a las ovejas puede ir a estudiar
pudiera estudiar al norte y ahí conocí a
mi esposa roxana
la recibí de veterinario y la profesión
me devolvió a la patagonia
y el ser veterinario me permitió entrar
en el ministerio de salud de la
provincia de chubut
trabajé con pequeños productores
y la hidatidosis me trajo a esta zona me
trajo a la zona sur de chubut
también la hidatidosis me permitió ir a
encuentros científicos a jornadas a
congresos
y ahí conocí a los que saben
a los que saben mucho de esta enfermedad
pero también conocí a los
charly estás a los que hablan
la hidatidosis me permitió conocer toda
argentina chile bolivia brasil uruguay
perú méxico portugal españa
pero lo más importante que en muchos de
estos lugares pude conocer a los
pequeños productores a aquellos que
tienen cabras ovejas llamas cuyos hijos
padecen hidatidosis y toda la familia
toda la familia sufre cuando uno de sus
hijos tiene ideas y dosis
hidatidosis me transformó en
investigador cuando hace 20
20 años conocí a un neozelandés en un
congreso está visite a un nervio
holandés marca like tower que estaban
preocupados por hidatidosis buscando una
vacuna
que nos pudiera proteger a nosotros de
esta enfermedad
muchos países trabajamos en esto mucha
gente muchos técnicos muchos científicos
muchos investigadores
muchísimo trabajo muchísimo trabajo
y al final logramos una vacuna la vacuna
recombinante eg95 una vacuna que tiene
la maravilla que aplicada en la oveja
aplicada a la cabra picada en la llama
nos protege a nosotros
protege a nuestros hijos
y todo esto fue el origen
de nuestro centro de investigación en
zoonosis en sarmiento
la historia nos dice que hace unos 14
mil años el hombre primitivo si su amigo
del lobo
querido sus cachorros y fue el origen
del perro doméstico
con la ayuda de ese perro doméstico a la
oveja doméstico a la cabra
los técnicos siempre nos preguntamos
cuándo va a parecido al primer parásito
en un perro o el primer quiste
hidatídico en una oveja de una llama
si sabemos que hace 2500 años los
médicos de estos tiempos describieron
lesiones en nuestro hígado en nuestros
pulmones similares a los que hoy
llamamos quiste hidatídico
también la historia nos dice que hace
165 años
la ciencia empezó a cerrar este ciclo
y descubrió que para que el par el
perrito tenga el parásito que producirá
acidosis debe comer hígado los pulmones
con quiste hidatídico
meses semanas después cuando el perrito
hace caca
junto con la cajita del perro salen los
huevos del parásito que contaminan el
medio ambiente decimos nosotros
el medio ambiente su impacto es el agua
es el patio de nuestra casa en la plaza
de nuestro pueblo es la medida de
nuestra casa
cuando la oveja o la cabra o la vaca o
la llama comen pasto a tomar agua les
crecen los christie de atípicos
y en la mayoría de las veces el que le
ofrece el hígado y el pulmón a nuestro
perro es el hombre cuando carne
nos preguntamos cómo nos enfermamos
nosotros
muy fácil tenemos que comer caca de
perro
ustedes dirán es difícil comer caca de
perro piensen los adultos
cada vez que el perrito nos remite a la
mano nos da besito en la cara ratito
antes se limpió su cola con la lengua y
lo más importante de nuestros chicos que
cuando castigan están igual que el que
la cabra o el corderito la boquita
contra el suelo y todo lo que encuentran
en el piso lo llevan a la boca y pueden
llevar un poquito de caca de perro ahí
teníamos el conocimiento y eso es
fantástico cuando conocemos algo podemos
intervenir
podemos actuar
y de ahí hace 163 años en islandia se
inició el primer programa de control de
hidatidosis un folletito con pocas
palabras que decía que no había que
darle las vísceras crudas a los perros
primera medida relevante
hace 50 años la industria nos puso a
disposición los farmacéuticos una
pastillita que si se la doy al perro
mata el parásito segunda medida
relevante
nos entusiasmamos mucho con esto era
fácil controlar hidatidosis muchísimos
de los países los empezaron programas de
control argentina también y tuvo también
solo pequeñas islas lograron el control
islandia y la malvina chipre tamaña
nueva zelanda
lección
hace 40 años que iniciamos y esta
historia se la voy a contar yo porque
fui parte de ella
hace 34 años
me instalaron en la zona sur en alto río
senguer me dieron una camioneta
me dieron unos folletos
y me dijeron usted tiene que luchar con
calidad y dos usted tiene que controlar
hidatidosis trabajamos mucho
desparasitados y estudiamos las cajitas
los perros colocamos anovulatorios a las
perras las operamos educación con el
ecógrafo buscamos quistes hidatídicos en
la gente sacando sangre buscábamos
parásitos
y esto se resume en eso que están viendo
ustedes
en el año 84 más de 30 personas con
hidatidosis por año ahora menos de 5
sería un técnico exitoso
cada chico
acá o en cualquier región del mundo que
tiene un quiste hidatídico
solo nos dice una frase
usted no me supo cuidar
me dice usted fracaso
usted no cumplió con su deber
y nosotros como técnico fracasamos
porque hoy se están enfermando chicos
tenemos muchísimas herramientas de
educación
no solo un folletito como tenían hoy
delante ese radio televisión internet
esto de hoy que es fantástico
sabemos qué hacer en las huertas sabemos
cómo controlar la población canina
sabemos cómo controlar la faena
sabemos cómo desparasitar los perros y
encima de hace unos poquitos años
tenemos esta tercera herramienta
relevante que es la vacunación
podemos vacunar ovejas y cabras
en definitiva
los técnicos tenemos todas las
herramientas
tenemos todas las estrategias tenemos el
conocimiento
podemos controlar y batidos
pero eso no es suficiente
necesitamos algo más
necesitamos que otra gente nos ayude
necesitamos que aquellos en chubut en
argentina o en la región del mundo donde
se están enfermando niños de hidatidosis
los que manejan las políticas sanitarias
tomen la decisión de controlar esta
enfermedad
y necesitamos que aquellos que deciden
donde volcar los recursos del estado
tomen la decisión de apoyar a los
programas de control divertidos
si eso ocurre
los que trabajamos en ir a ti dosis
podemos comenzar a pensar y a soñar un
chubut una argentina un mundo sin
hidatidosis
y los técnicos
y las familias que sufren
hoy chicos con hidatidosis le podemos
gritar a los cuatro vientos
hidatidosis que vamos a ganar
[Música]
y